[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
enfant j'ai fait un rêve celui de
devenir un homme
croyez moi ce n'est pas un homme avec
les attributs que vous imaginez un homme
une personne capable de changer les
choses
d'apporter le changement d'améliorer les
conditions conditions de vie mais celle
aussi des autres je suis karidja
tadiello je suis jeune femme africaine
je suis mère de deux enfants
je suis aussi entrepreneur et c'est à ce
titre que je suis devant vous dans cette
assemblée enfants disait j'ai fait un
rêve celui de devenir un homme
enfant j'avais pas droit
l'éducation à l'école je veux dire cela
ne faisait pas partie des rêves de mon
père mais je comprends c'était ses rêves
mais grâce à la générosité et à la halle
à la à la détermination d'hommes et de
femmes de mon entourage j'ai eu la
chance d'aller à l'école
enfant j'ai pas échappé à l'excision et
aux violences sexuelles
mais cela m'a permis de comprendre que à
des moments donnés de la vie des adultes
prennent des décisions pensant est très
bonne mais c'est leur décision
ce sont leurs rêves du moment pour
respecter la tradition et je respecte
ses traditions enfant j'ai fait un rêve
j'ai fait le rêve d'aller au delà de mes
limites
l'excision et ces violences ne devraient
certainement rien enlever de mes rêves
certes elles m'ont peut être enlevé
quelque chose physiquement mais je me
reste mais mes rêves je reste dans ma
tête
enfant j'ai échappé aux mariages forcés
à 15 ans je devais être mariée et j'ai
découvert un après midi pendant que je
j'apprenais mes cours de sciences
naturelles qu'on appelle svt aujourd'hui
qu'il se préparait quelque chose dans le
salon de mes parents j'ai fait irruption
dans ce salon et j'ai découvert qu'il
s'agissait de mon projet de mariage
j'étais assez déçu parce que je
travaillais bien en classe je me disais
bien mais tout ça ne va pas s'arrêter
maintenant je vous raconte l'anecdote je
suis rentré dans la salle et j'ai dit à
mon père mais papa pourquoi veux-tu me
vendre que je fais et il m'a dit sors de
là part et je suis parti en larmes
j'ai repris mes cahiers mais mes hommes
étaient là pour se tenir débout commence
comme un seul homme oui j'ai sept frères
mes sept frères étaient là avec à leur
tête mon frère aîné ou dire non c'est
pas possible on ne va pas la vendre
elle ira à l'école et elle sera la
meilleure pour ensuite me dire tu sais
que le vieux il va te vendre de toutes
les manières si tu ne travailles pas
bien en classe
alors est ce que j'avais le choix
non je n'avais pas le choix donc quand
je travaillais bien en classe que je
ramenais de meilleures notes
c'était pour mon propre plaisir et
surtout pour sauver ma peau je n'avais
pas envie d'être mariée en tout cas pas
à l'âge de 15 ans jeune adulte j'ai eu
du travail
j'ai connu le bonheur d'être salarié
j'ai travaillé dans des multinationales
et j'avais de très bons salaires je vous
assure
et c'était très bien j'ai été habitué
même j'ai fini par m'habituer à cette
simplicité et à me dire que c'était bien
que je resterai comme ça mais le temps a
passé et finalement mes rêves me
rattraper n'oubliez pas enfant j'ai fait
un rêve celui de devenir un homme peut
changer les choses et à un moment donné
je disais à mon à mon collègue qui doit
être certainement dans la salle a qu'un
tweet il faut que j'aille dehors le rêve
m'appelle dehors je dois y aller
croyez moi ce n'était pas une décision
facile parce que je paraissais com
fou pour ma famille pour tous ceux qui
comptaient compter sur moi pour mes amis
aussi
mais j'ai fait le rêve j'ai fait le rêve
d'apporter quelque chose à l'humanité et
j'avais pas le choix je me suis lancé
dans l'entrepreneuriat j'ai donc créé en
2012 ma première entreprise et et j'ai
continué j'ai aimé les accès story j'ai
aimé les premiers contrats
j'ai aimé de signer deux d'exécuter un
marché j'ai aimé de transformer mon
employeur en clients et fournisseurs à
qui je dis merci pour la confiance
qu'elle me fait et ensuite j'ai connu
des échecs
j'ai connu la solitude de l'entrepreneur
j'ai connu des contrats non exécutées
faute de moyens j'ai connu cette
souffrance et j'ai entendu des phrases
croyait tu que ce serait facile
oui on m'a souvent répété cette phrase
mais n'oubliez pas enfant j'ai fait un
rêve celui de devenir un homme
je continue j'ai donc à la suite crié
active active pour ne plus jamais rester
seul pour apprendre des autres pour
apprendre aux autres active est une
association qui milite pour
l'entreprenariat des femmes pour que
nous partageons ensemble nos expériences
et que finalement nos rêves soit
possible nous avons ouvert la maison
active et au sein de la maison active
nous avons pris le soin d'ouvrir une
garderie parce que nous savons à quel
point les les enfants peuvent être un
frein à l'épanouissement professionnel
de leurs de leur maman donc à la maison
active vous trouverez une garderie et
j'espère que ce sera très grande cette
maison et qu'elle existera un peu
partout en côte d'ivoire et à travers le
monde
alors mon message
à toutes les petites filles qui
m'écoutent attingre et la radio coûts et
à sikasso à tombouctou en inde à qui
l'on a dit qu'elle n'avait pas droit à
l'éducation j'ai envie de leur dire que
cela est possible le changement arrive
il faut qu'elles tiennent bon à toutes
ces petites filles qui me coûte qui ont
subi des violences sexuelles qui ont
subi l'excision un peu partout dans le
monde
je voudrais leur dire qu'on leur a
certes enlevé quelque chose physiquement
mais leur rêve d'en rester intacte elles
doivent apporter quelque chose elles
doivent tenir bon j'y suis arrivé grâce
à la providence mais aussi grâce à la
bénédiction de mes parents mes parents
et leurs bénédictions m'accompagne au
quotidien et je n'ai pas peur parce que
je sais qu'ils seront là mais mon
silence ils sont toujours là enfin à
toutes les femmes du monde entier
je voudrais que nous servions de modèle
à ses petites filles et à ces femmes que
nous nous mettions ensemble pour
poursuivre ce rêve
enfant j'ai fait un rêve celui de
devenir un homme
enfant j'ai fait le rêve d'inspirer
toutes les petites filles d'afrique
je poursuis ma marge
[Applaudissements]